what did you do what is causing these
tremors
i thought you could tell me i completed
the four rituals just like the board
told me to the astral bleed should have
stopped
look it has stopped the nail is repaired
but we have a new problem my analysis of
the nail indicates that it is
literally a piece of the astral plane or
possibly a vessel containing the astral
plane
or both either way right now both
dimensions are vibrating a completely
incompatible frequencies
the spatial friction they are generating
is incalculable
it's going to destroy both planes
i messed this all up maybe marshall was
right to destroy the nail
i should have left it in pieces no then
the astral plane would still be leaking
in
sometimes there's no right answer jesse
we need more information
no i need to fix this now
i'll just i'll figure something out
no we should really make a plan the
tremors are originating from directly
below us but we don't know
what perfect i'll head down and take
care of whatever's going on
just do what you can from here jesse you
can't just
i have to emily i'm the director
this is on me
[Music]
that was just the top of the nail how
much deeper does the foundation go
crystals are going
crazy here it's almost like they're
trying to stop me
[Music]
[Applause]
marshall blew up the nail the board
attacked her
i don't [ __ ] like it
[Music]
nobody else here this is the director
i need a ranger at this location
immediately
it's an honor director
marshall you're
alive soon you will no longer recognize
us
or yourself or him or her
or them family is dead the walls are
broken but
yellow and red goddammit is made right
everything i am not letting you take
this
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
boss
oh
foreign
[Music]
this
ugh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sorry i wasn't here to help marshall
the nail was corrupted that explains why
the board wasn't answering
what's causing the quakes marshall came
down here to stop this
i should have been with her i could have
saved her
that i can still save everyone else
[Music]
oh
well [ __ ] you too oh
i'll be sure to let's play it smart
they don't need to know i'm on to them
not yet anyway
uh
the nail is secure the hiss can't touch
it
i can't undo the astral bleeding in the
foundation but at least
it stopped along with the seismic
activity
you did it jessie did you ever find
marshall
i did she's gone
she died thinking she'd save the bureau
not a bad way to go
i wasn't ready for this crisis i didn't
even see it coming
but i promise i'll be ready for the next
one
i mean what good is a director who can't
hold her bureau together
[Music]
[Music]
i thought i know how to handle things
now that i'm the director
clearly it's not that simple